all right Jasmine
Jasmine uh where are you from originally
where'd you grow up I grew up in a
suburb around like 20 minutes outside of
Portland Oregon so that's where I was
born and raised um both of my parents
are immigrants from Iran
so uh they were born over there I was
born they came my dad came after the
revolution in 1979 and then my mom came
just a couple years before I was born
um my mom's a lawyer my dad's an
engineer I had a very traditional I
would say
iranian-american immigrant life in the
sense of like very rigid academic
expectations
um I used to literally get my phone
taken away if I got like a b so like it
was like straight A's
um
you know the whole what do you want to
be when you grow up is kind of like okay
do you want to be a lawyer doctor or
engineer like there isn't much of like
what are you passionate about you know I
was actually passionate about psychology
so that's what I actually majored in in
college and my parents like that's fine
but you have to go get a PhD so it's
like you know
um
yeah so I was like all right well I'm
scared of blood so I don't want to be a
doctor I don't like math so I don't want
to be an engineer my mom's a lawyer and
school kind of comes easily to me so I
mean intelligence is multi-faceted but
school for me was always
I'm book smart so it was not that hard
and then
um went to college graduated summa [__]
laude 4.0 took the LSAT scored within I
don't know what percent but like well
within the top 10 percent so got a full
ride scholarship to a great law school
and was like okay I guess I'm going to
be a lawyer
um
it's never like what I wanted to do but
I didn't know what I wanted to do so I
was just like okay it was like kind of
just going through the motions so I
liked having or I felt comfortable
having like a path set out okay
especially if it's based on tests okay
take the LSAT cool okay you got into
this school school is going to be how
law school works is your whole grade is
just based on your final exam
so I was like great I can kind of [__]
around all semester and then just cram
in the last couple of weeks have a
mental breakdown do well and then do it
all again so
I was I was fine with all of that and I
like school I like learning but I was
always like I don't want to graduate I
was looking for ways to not graduate in
the sense of like well what if I go get
an llm stay another year like trying to
find ways to do more schooling
because I just the thought of
actually practicing or going this is
going to sound
and I still feel this way and I felt
this way at the time too that I'm just
being spoiled and part of it maybe is
like I just didn't want to get up every
day and go to a nine to five and have
like billable hours I had grown up
seeing my mom work at a big firm and she
was at work usually till about eight or
nine PM
um and I just didn't have like that kind
of ambition
so as graduation was nearing and
everyone else is super excited to
graduate I feel like like in college you
will get people who are like oh
um you know I don't know what to do when
I graduate but in law school like
everyone is ready to go like there they
have a mission they're there they want
to get licensed and they're ready to
practice and I was just
like dreading it and covid hit um in the
middle of my 2L year which is like your
second year so law school's three years
and so then we were like online
and I didn't even fully connected at the
time but like my mental health was kind
of like deteriorating because I was just
like every single event in my life or
anything I was looking at I was looking
at it okay is this before I graduate or
after I graduate it's like I thought I
was going to die after I graduated it
was very weird but it's because I was
like
there is nothing I want to do that
involves me being like having a normal
job and even though I was like there are
Fields I'm interested in like I could
even work for a non-profit go into the
public sector I mean then I was worried
that I wouldn't
um make good money and I did want to
make money but also like
I just don't want that life
um
but being a lawyer wasn't for you being
a lawyer just wasn't for me and but then
it's like almost any job where you're
going in the alarm goes off it's Monday
morning you go into the office happy
Monday happy Friday like I just didn't
want that but I was like okay I don't
think anyone else wants that either this
is just life this is just reality you're
being spoiled you were born pretty much
with a silver spoon in your mouth you've
had everything given to you so now
you're gonna sit here and complain about
this so I was like okay I guess this is
just life like I guess this is just
gonna be you know what it is and so
graduated in May of 2021
bar was in July of 2021 I think that's
when I discovered your videos and I
literally had like soft white underbelly
and then like my boyfriend like in two
different tabs on my um on my laptop and
I was like okay and you between May and
July what most law students do is all
you do is study for the bar and I I
study last minute so I was like well
what do I do in the meantime I had a
friend in law school who started like a
secret only fans and she was telling me
about it and I was like wait
I got really curious about it so I had
heard of it in like 2020 and like the
midst of the pandemic like everyone was
talking about how only fans was blowing
up at that time I had no social media I
didn't have an Instagram I didn't have a
Facebook like I haven't had social media
before I started only fans since like
Myspace when I was like in middle school
so it just didn't seem like something I
could ever do because I'm like I don't
even like know how to use the internet I
barely still know how to use the
internet to be fair
um
but I saw she had done it and I'm like
well how do you do it like where do you
post and she's like oh I post on Reddit
and I I had heard of Reddit but I didn't
like know what it is and so I kind of
asked her how she did it and then the
nice thing about how I started was it
was so low pressure because I didn't
need to be doing it like it was just
kind of like I actually remember there
were these shoes I wanted that were like
500 and my parents weren't gonna buy
them for me because up until that point
my parents had been like funding my life
my dad had actually just bought me a
house
super low pressure
all I need is this 500 so I can buy
these shoes and you know how like if you
make more than 600 it gets like report I
was like okay I'm not even gonna make
600 so who cares
and
um I started on Reddit and I made that
in like the first
24 hours
um I like just posted in like busty
brunettes or something and it did really
well so I was like oh okay so then I
just kind of was like studying for the
bar watching soft white underbelly and
doing my only fans that's all I was
doing for like a month
and it it did really well like my my
only fans was doing especially for like
it being brand new me having no social
media presence me just using Reddit and
Reddit is still my main platform like
millions of followers on there
um and so I took the bar
and then it was like okay well what now
and I was like well I'm making all this
money now I'm just gonna put off getting
a job and I would just tell my parents
oh it's covid like no one's hiring like
you know
um but then uh from an old like
externship I did somebody reached out
and they're like this person's hiring
you should go and I remember I was like
[__] because I knew I couldn't justify
not going
um so I was like okay I probably won't
get it anyway and I literally had like
long like just I didn't look
professional and even in law school I
was always different I would go to law
school like this like I would wear crop
tops
um there's like a running joke I have
with like me and my friends from law
school that like nobody would have
expected me to do this but if there was
like a graduation like most likely to
and if there was like a category for
most likely to quit law and do only I
would win it like hands down I would win
it even though it's still such a like
crazy easy move
um but I was like you know always coming
in late I'd sit in the back I had my
little heels I'd bring like banana
breads from Starbucks for like all my
friends like I was just I didn't I
always had a little bit of an I don't
give a [__] attitude I always had a
little bit of that I wasn't rebellious
in the sense of like I never got in
trouble like nothing like that I don't
drink I don't do drugs but I kind of
also was like well
why can't I wear this to school like
okay so people might think it's weird
you know and and in in those settings No
One's Gonna like say anything to you
they're just gonna like think it and
honestly it actually made me
um
like I know I got certain jobs and
opportunities because like like for
instance I'd clerk for a judge and the
judge just liked me because I was
different because I didn't come in with
like a cookie cutter little suit in my
briefcase and sit there and be like okay
well here's my accomplishments like I
was just come in and I was just myself
and I was different and that's something
especially nowadays schools are looking
for
um firms are looking for judges are even
looking for so I actually always did
well and I did well in school so like
even though I looked so different my
reputation was kind of like she might
not even come to class if she does come
to class she's gonna come like pretty
much in a bikini but she's gonna do well
like I will do well on the exam and
that's all that really um
mattered but anyway so I got the job on
the spot
and I don't think anyone was more sad to
get a job in their life you didn't want
it no because at that point I was
already making like five times what I
was gonna make as a starting salary even
in the private sector as an even like
big law many like I was already so I was
like I don't need to do this but at the
same time like I was like what am I
gonna do like not be a lawyer and do
only fans like that's crazy like not
doing that so I remember actually called
my sister because she knew and I was
like I got this job and she's like good
thank God now Mom and Dad can like relax
I'm like but I don't want nothing but I
don't want it she's like are you [__]
stupid like what is wrong with you like
fine do only fans but just do both and I
was like oh okay so now this was like
October and I was doing a double life it
was so weird I would be in the office
like normal business hours a lot of that
point I was like shadowing learning
whatever but then I come home and like
do only fans like stuff with toys take
news and I would spend a lot of my
weekends curating
um content for the rest of the week
because it was very important to me to
be consistent and to because I was like
this is a business like if I want to
keep making this money I have to keep I
can't just only fans there's a lot of
work yeah it is
um I've heard it is so I would spend
like all my weekends doing that and then
come back into the office on Monday and
everyone's like what'd you do this
weekend and all the other like oh I went
and saw the Opera like you know just
those kind of people and I'm like oh I
just you know had like a chill relaxing
weekend but when I'm like looking back
I'm like sucking dildos like just all
kinds of [__] and nobody knew
um I was always worried that they would
find out and so every time like my boss
would like tell me to come into her
office or something I'm like she knows
like this is the moment they found about
my only fans
um and so I did that for like six or
seven months and and then I was just
like sitting there one day and I'm like
why am I here and I was at this point
like my growth was like when I started
was going up and up and up and then once
I started working that like
six seven months it was stagnant because
I just I wasn't able to like you know
spend a lot of time on it and look for
opportunities to grow try out other
platforms I was even scared to try other
platforms because I'm like okay Reddit
is kind of underground like you have to
be looking for this kind of content on
Reddit to find it so I'm like okay even
if like a client like recognizes me what
are they going to be like I was looking
at busty brunettes on Reddit and I found
you like there you know it's just like
it's kind of like okay underground thing
but I didn't want to start any other
forms of social media I didn't want to
get put my name out there I didn't want
to bring my story into it and that is a
lot of success I think with platforms
like only fans like it is the physical
but if you look at like the top earners
on only fans a lot of them
um are like social media personalities
like they're streamers they they um
they interact and you need time to
interact you need time to go live you
need time to do all that so I was like
okay I'm literally waking up every day
I'm losing money
to go to work which like imagine your
alarm going off in the morning and all
you can think of is like I'm gonna make
less money by getting out of bed right
now it was horrible everyone at my firm
was super nice and actually like a
couple uh I mean I didn't tell everybody
but a couple of them now and they're
super supportive but
that was also a thing is I'm like I've
if any if this was even a little bit
worse I would just quit but this is like
as good of an experience I can get as a
first year associate like
no mean Partners everybody's nice work
life balance is great they're not even
worried about my billables right now
like I don't I felt like I didn't have
an excuse to quit and I also think that
there was part of me that was like I
have to have one foot in the store
as it was like comforting it's like okay
yeah I do only fans but I'm really a
lawyer my career is still a lawyer I'm a
lawyer I still have your dignity I still
have yeah I have my dignity if you want
is there we can get into that but I
could like go out and just be a lawyer
and just have like a secret only fans
and there was still like comfort in that
um
and then one day I was sitting there and
I was like okay what are the actual
reasons you're still here right and I
actually made a physical list and I
realized all of them had to do with
other people like all them had to do
with other people and then there was
like you know the common what are you
gonna do in 10 years and I'm like well
hopefully not be in an office and
starting my only fans was kind of like
the first thing I really did
that no one else told me to do because
my whole life it's like okay go get good
grades okay go take this test okay go go
to school okay get a job apply okay
whatever you know
um and this was the first thing that I
just kind of was like I'm gonna do this
why not and at this point my parents
knew so I kind of told I told my mom
um and I was really close with both of
my parents especially my dad
um common misconception that we all have
daddy issues I definitely do not if
anything my dad spoiled like my dad
really spoiled me to go back to your
childhood for a second yeah you had a
great childhood great childhood
uh both parents in my life very close
with both of them no sexual abuse
nothing you're just I wasn't even
allowed like my parents I mean the old I
was they were just strict like even now
if I go home like I can't be out all
night like I have to be home by like
midnight growing up my parents I wasn't
allowed to go on sleepovers because they
were afraid someone else right so that's
very common Even in our culture like
they don't let you like even go out and
and because they're so afraid that
someone's gonna murder you or you know
whatever but super involved both my
parents especially my dad because my mom
worked such long hours my dad was like
you know I had one of those childhoods
okay piano practice is six
skating practice is seven
Farsi School Persian at a Sunday morning
like we had like those jam-packed
swimming lessons I've taken it all art
classes everything my dad would take us
um uh and he was super involved like my
dad did most of the cooking cleaning
super like I remember every time he'd go
to work and they had like muffins he
would bring one home for me one home for
my sister he would wake up in the middle
of the night when we were kids multiple
times a night and come put the covers on
us
um we really like especially me because
my sister at least for undergrad she
went um she wanted to like start
becoming more independent I was like I
don't so I actually even in law school
my first year because I never had like
washed dishes I would just throw them
away and buy new ones like I actually I
I'm I'm still it's very difficult for I
don't know I don't have those basic like
I remember it was like what a couple
months ago that this is gonna sound so
stupid but I didn't realize when you
vacuumed something like like the vacuum
still like I thought it like disappeared
into the metaverse or so I had no idea
um how those like household things work
because my dad
always did that for us like he cooked
for us I still don't know how to cook
um doordash every meal
um and he you know when I was moving
even he drove my car he unpacked
everything like he is such a good dad to
the point where like I I know everyone
says oh I have the best parents in the
world like my dad might actually be the
best parent in the world not saying my
mom isn't but my dad just goes above and
beyond to the point where when I was
growing up like I mean until recently he
was still like making our dentist
appointments and stuff but I remember
like everywhere we went like I'd go to
the dentist I'd go to the doctor every
single
um person would say your dad loves you
and your sister so much like he was just
known for being
for loving us that much like when we go
to daycare after school programs and
stuff everyone knew my dad because he'd
be calling a bunch of times like oh you
got you guys have to pick her up from
school and they're like yes we know you
know the first time we did it he
actually followed the car made sure that
he's like I saw you get in the bus like
he was very Hands-On and he was great
and he was so amazing so that was the
one
and it still is the biggest point of
contention with what I do
is how much it disappointed him do you
feel guilt I feel guilt yeah yeah
um and
with my mom I I was just like so I told
her because I was just so afraid of the
secret coming out and if I if it was
going to come out I wanted to come out
on my own terms that's one thing about
me I don't like giving other people the
opportunity to like ruin my day like if
anyone's gonna ruin my day it's gonna be
me I don't want to like you know be
woken up at 2AM by my mom like finding
this out like I don't understand how I
mean to each their own but people who
like live with someone and sleep and
they have like full-blown Affairs like I
just it would disrupt my piece too much
because I'd be so afraid that my life is
gonna be flipped upside down at any
moment I don't know when and then I just
look [__] dumb because I did
something and I just wasn't honest about
it so I had told my mom dad know how
much you make
uh
yes now he does or he knows like the
ballpark
um but which is impressive yeah and and
now you use your use your wildest
imagination and then double it he he
literally now like every time I talk to
him he's like save your money save your
money save your money save your money
like now he's just so worried that I'm
not gonna blow the money
um which is a big shift from how it
first started so I told her I was
actually angry about something and I
think I used that anger to like not at
her I was angry about something else but
I was riled up
and I had the courage in that moment
because I was so full of emotion so I
called her I was like
and she's like what and the only reason
she knew it and only fans was was
because like I think Christmas break one
year I like went home and I was telling
her about it and she was like appalled
because my parents
I would say they're not conservative
compared to other maybe Middle Eastern
households like you know we weren't
super religious I didn't like go to a
mosque growing up like I mean I couldn't
wear like short shorts and stuff but
generally like
they were what but compared to like
American households like yeah I couldn't
go places as much they had the Iranian
culture more conservative conservative
so like for instance my mom didn't like
date or touch or hold hands with anyone
until she met my dad like she she used
to tell me like tampons are for married
women like very much like the okay you
need to keep your hymen intact until
until your wedding night like they just
grew up like that so I wasn't allowed to
have I had a boyfriend were you exposed
to this wild sexual life when was I
exposed to this yeah how did you
I don't have a wild sexual well you're I
mean only fans but uh before that I
didn't
um so I wasn't allowed to have a
boyfriend like I couldn't have a
boyfriend and then I got my boyfriend
now no but I did have one when I was
like 19 was like when I had my first
boyfriend and I still had to be home oh
my God he was a great boyfriend because
he would drive 40 minutes because my
parents also were like you can't drive
at night by yourself because someone's
gonna kill you so he had to drive 40
minutes pick me up and then drive me to
his house and then I had to be home at
12 so then he would have to drive me
back at 12. we could never spend the
night together
um and this went on until I moved
I still like you know so they were
strict in in that sense and they I think
even now they don't understand that
pornography like they think pornography
is like
like a bikini like I don't think they
even know because they're just not
internet Savvy
um that people actually like have sex
like maybe they have an abstract idea
but I don't think they really get it
because like my mom like if you see like
JLo in a bikini she's like oh I don't
want to see these news I'm like it's on
a magnet this is not this is not nudes
um yeah exactly so I don't think even
now they fully know but they know I'm
doing something bad let's just say that
they know it's bad
she freaked out she actually didn't talk
to me
um and my mom had never done that never
I remember I called her office
and
she like purposely didn't answer and she
never in her life had done that so I was
like oh [__]
um and at the time my dad was actually
visiting because this was actually so
she found out before the bar
and my dad was like bringing me fruit
bowls like okay do you need anything
else to study and I'm like no and I was
like mortified like okay you know you
need to focus on this test but I really
didn't want my dad to know but I also
knew that like if I'm going to keep
doing this like
how is he not gonna know right so my mom
and my sister and I I guess they all
have this family meeting which I didn't
know at the time but I could kind of
guess because the way that my dad called
me and like spoke I was like he didn't
come up with this on the fly like
um and I think they had my dad call me
because they knew that if anyone could
change my mind it would be my dad like
my dad's the only one that could
make me stop doing this so he calls me
and he's like I know what you're doing
very disappointed in you I don't know
why you're doing this because this is
for people that come from X background
this is for people that have you know
don't have money don't have a good
family clearly somebody got in your head
and someone's a bad influence on you
because obviously you would never choose
to do this you just don't know what
you're doing but you know what it's okay
just stop now donate all the money to
charity I think on that one they might
have like been like fine even if you
don't want to but he's like donate all
the money to charity stop now and go
back on the right path but like in the
right accent they go back on zerite path
and I'm like and I just remember sitting
there listening to him
and I was just like no and I was even
shocked when I said that because I had
never said that and even my dad's like
what I was like
no I'm like I don't want to I'm like I
like this and
this is but at the time I was like but
I'm still a lawyer right like I'm still
working and it's just something I'm
doing on the side it's totally fine
everybody does it like trying to
um lessen the blow but
it was the first time that it was like
every fiber of my being is like you
can't do that because I think I knew
like you have this window you have this
opportunity
that you can get out of that nine to
five life that you've always wanted that
you didn't think was possible it could
be possible so so you must get offers of
of in person oh all the time I mean like
people want you to show up at their
doorstep oh yeah I mean it and I and I
get it people do
work that okay you would probably do in
person for the right price did you don't
do that I don't what kind of offers have
you had um
um I like have so many people up
for me like two hundred fifty thousand
hundred thousand the most I ever got was
four hundred thousand for just one night
and they're like I like these super
super wealthy men who just you know um
because there's like a thing like a lot
of um like I said there's not a lot of
Middle Eastern girls doing this so
there's like these Arab guys who love
like Persian women and they're like oh
my God you're like my dream girl I will
pay just give me the price
I just want one night with you so I get
crazy offers for in person
um I just don't take them not because I
have a moral issue with it I would just
it would just make me uncomfortable
um but you're making enough as is
exactly which is crazy it's crazy that I
literally can sit there and rationalize
like I don't really need that 250
000 like it'd be nice I'm not saying it
wouldn't be but it's not something that
I would like fly to another country for
or like I just couldn't picture myself
actually like I would have to like and I
don't do drugs like I'd have to like be
drunk to do it but it's crazy that I get
so many offers like that so only fans
has kind of change everything in the
sense of we get to um we get to
advertise to the world
and there's a lot of wealthy people in
the world who see you and want a night
with you
what you're doing if you continued for
another five ten years you could make
enough money for the rest of your life
yeah exactly you won't need a man you
won't need no I don't know you won't
need anything exactly
um and I didn't what was the scope of it
at the time what is it what is it about
what you're doing that you like
is it entertaining men or is it making a
lot of money
it's the freedom
and it's the fact that I have this
audience so I'm I'm a very unique only
fans Creator so once a week I literally
get on stream and I talk about like
metaphysics and like breakdown like I
really and I have like a fan base now
like we have a Discord group for other
really intellectually curious people we
have like a book club it's very I know
it's very weird and I didn't even mean
to do that are you naked when you're
doing this no so what I do is on Monday
nights I do an hour and a half like
wearing clothes and I talk about like
anything like free will I just almost
like Phyllis because I love philosophy
and psych so a lot of topics like that
and then right after I go to only fans
and get butt naked and like do a live
orgasm right after and I've had so many
fans reach out to me like this is really
strange like I feel guilty jerking off
to you now because I feel like I've seen
it and I love when people send me that
because it's just I'm like why
like and then they're like yeah you're
right and then once they get exposed to
it a few times then it becomes normal
it's just people aren't used to seeing
like I I wouldn't say only fans creators
are porn stars but whatever I'm gonna
use like porn stars
in any other context other than like
sexual arousal and whatever so one of I
think the reasons only fans is popular
and it is what it is because you know
everyone's like oh porn is free why
would anyone pay for it is because they
like the person
and they feel like a connection to the
person or they think the person is
really cool and a lot of my fans like
feel that way and it's still so hard for
people because of the ideas we have
around sex and you know the societal
attitudes towards it and what we've been
taught the shame people see sex as
something oh I do it like private and
blah blah blah so when they're like wait
I just had like a great discussion with
you on live and then 20 minutes later
like
I'm seeing you naked and I'm horny like
they don't know how to deal with that
because it's so new and it's novel but
seeing so many people reach out to me in
that way and then come back a few months
later and they're like wow now I feel
fine with it like now it's so normal to
me like now I don't know how I felt that
way before they're assuming a girl that
would do what you do when you're naked
is a bimbo yeah they assume I'm not
smart they assume that I don't have any
other talents I mean that's the number
one thing like if I'm sitting on live
like this people are like you probably
don't know how to read a book it's like
I probably read more books in the past
month than you have in your life but you
know um
it's I break those
stereotypes and expectations that so
many people put on sex workers that it's
very even people who are supportive like
supportive of sex workers it's still so
hard for them to
um actually
like deal with it sometimes or
um so so yeah so that's why it's one of
the reasons I do it because I'm like I
mean so I understand some of the reasons
you do it yeah and the upside what are
some of the downsides of what you do
have only fans
um
so there are a lot that could be
downsides for other I don't think are
necessarily downsized for me so I have a
lot of like younger girls to see what
I'm doing and how much I'm making and
they're like I want to be like you I
want to be like you and I'm like I don't
think you're cut out for it like you get
a lot of hate
um especially for someone like me who
came from like the most respected
profession you get a lot of hate in in
because of what I do we're on Reddit or
um not Reddit because everyone's on
Reddit to look at porn but like
Instagram
um any anywhere where it's not for porn
I get a lot of hate a ton of hate and I
actually think I get more hate because
of my story that enrages people like if
I go on Instagram and I'm just like
shaking my tits I may get a few comments
like oh what does Society come to
whatever but if I go online and I'm like
hey guys the reason I went from being a
lawyer is to this is because I didn't
want to work people in it enrages people
that I had the background I did
and I'm a lawyer and I had this
well-respected profession and I chose to
do this it pisses people off to no end
because why do you think that is
because I'm embody
so many of us live the lives we live
because we feel like we're supposed to
and so not only am I challenging that
because it's like most people if you
don't like it's like the parts of life
that most people don't like like having
a job not having a nine to five like I
say that and they're like you're the
worst person ever life is all about
working yourself to the Bone I'm like
you don't actually want to be doing that
either but you're seeing me have this
opportunity to not do that by breaking a
societal Norm by being an example of
what it means to live life on my own
terms and live a life conducive to my
own happiness by stepping out of line
and that scares people that makes people
really uncomfortable it makes people
really uncomfortable when you almost I
want to say it's a social contract but
in a sense it's like okay this is what
happens and people like to categorize
people and so you hear this a lot oh sex
workers they're all abused they're all
damaged they all have so I get all the
time even sometimes people that are just
curious hey you're really smart why do
you do this like it's like this is seen
constantly as a last resort and for a
lot of women it is but for me it was the
first Resort because I could have done
anything I wanted to do you would never
be able to make the money as a lawyer
that you're making yeah and that's
another thing people don't understand is
people are like oh what are you going to
do in 10 years I'm like be retired like
like you know
um so if the money is part of it but
it's the fact that I'm choosing to do
something so that's so stigmatized and
I'm so open about it I'm so I don't give
a [__] that a lot of people it enrages
people and they they constantly are like
telling me oh they're like waiting for
the other shoe to drop I get so many
messages like well well okay fine but
you're gonna be lonely forever nobody's
ever gonna like you in 10 years you're
going to be we're gonna be working at
Taco Bell and it's like
okay it's like a Revenge fantasy thing
because they're unhappy with their life
obviously you get marriage proposals all
the time oh yeah and I mean I don't even
marriage isn't even something I'm really
into but like I mean yeah they're like
and then it turns into well no
uh self-respecting man would marry you
because someone under will comment like
I'll marry her and he's like no man who
really respects himself no high value
man like you hear this in like the new
Andrew Tate manosphere World high value
low value no high value man well your
kids your future kids I'm like you don't
really care if you cared about kids go
go volunteer and you know use your
resources on kids that are alive that
actually need you today don't worry
about my hypothetical children 15 plus
years
um but that's what they it's like people
can't accept that someone may live a
lifestyle that you don't approve of or
someone got somewhere in a way that you
don't think they earned it or they got
something the easy way and they might
still just be happy and it might just
work out for them like people don't like
that they're like no just wait until you
see her in 10 years wait till you see
her in 15 years it's like you're going
to be depressed yeah you're going to be
depressed this is what always happens to
people like you you say that now when
your looks fade and nobody wants you
because your your tits are all over the
Internet what are you gonna do then and
I'm just like what if because it's very
likely that won't happen like I might
actually just go on and live like a
decent life and if that the thought of
that bothers you like if the thought of
me
actually just going on and living a
happy and healthy life with people who
share my values because there's billions
of people in this world we all have
different values like you can go off and
be happy with your social conservative
values and there are plenty of people
who don't hold your values if that
enrages you why like why does it enrage
you why does it bother you if you sit
there and you you don't like me and you
don't like what I do and you don't like
the decision I made and if you're coping
by being like well she's going to be
miserable later stop and think what if
I'm not and if that bothers you reflect
why
what am I like you know what I mean like
why does me going off and living a life
maybe that you don't approve of why does
that bother you if I'm not miserable
people are so uptight about sex very
uptight about sex especially because of
I'm a middle eastern so there's not a
lot of Middle Eastern women that do this
and we have more a more conservative
culture so I get a ton of like people
well that's also one of the reasons I'm
successful is you know Middle Eastern
women don't typically do this so since I
do this I do get I get a lot of like a
lot of my fan base especially originally
was Middle Eastern so I get a ton of
messages like that but you know what I
get a ton of messages from people being
like hey I'm gay and I'm Iranian I'm X
and I'm Iranian and you being so open
and choosing to do this and disobey our
parents because people we don't do that
like we don't come from like the Western
individualistic culture of I do what I
want my happiness it's like no you
respect your parents you do what your
parents tell you you can't disappoint or
bring shame to your parents that's
selfish of you you're selfish you're
narcissistic I've heard it all that
other creators don't get because of my
background
and I get so many messages from people
being like hey like you inspired me even
out of the Middle East like I'm bisexual
no one here like understands that so
your story has inspired me like those
messages mean more to me it's really
funny because people are like oh as a
lawyer you could have been helping
people like most of my job honestly was
helping really rich people avoid taxes
but
um people are like you could have
touched so many people as a lawyer and
honestly I could have never touched as
many people as a lawyer as I have as a
sex worker sharing my story and just
being unapologetically myself are you
happy
yes you seem to be I'm happy like I I
have a good life so it doesn't mean
everything's perfect it doesn't mean
there's no room for improvement I it's a
lonely profession because you're home
all the time and I'm introverted anyway
so I'm gonna ask a question which I
think is stupid but I I know the answer
but yeah uh as a sex worker are you
lonely because you can't find a good man
no yeah I know I know yeah you suffer
from like the Paradox of choice yeah
because there's so many you have too
many to choose from and something that a
lot of people don't realize they're
great guys too yeah is like how do I say
this
more educated people are less anti-sex
work in general so like you know
Academia leans left and and so the
messages I get like you [__] [__]
they're not coming from other lawyers or
doctors they're coming from and you can
tell like I it's so crazy how much of a
stark contrast I have in the grammar
spelling of like my hate comments like I
think there's like a four percent
success rate in using the correct form
of your right and those versus like the
messages that are like you know other
people other lawyers I get messages all
the time from them like
you made it out like that's amazing I
was on a podcast with a couple attorneys
not long ago and they're like we
actually saw your story on the attorney
page and all the comments were positive
like even people who are may have like
hold more conservative values themselves
they don't see like they're not like you
[__] [__] like they just don't think
like that so there's actually a lot of
really intelligent Great Men Who
have no issue with what I do like I've
I've dated in the past couple years and
not there was one guy and even him like
he just I was like I had an
unconventional career shift and he's
like don't say only fans and I'm like
only fans and even he was just like he
still is on my ass and I just don't talk
to him because I'm like I don't like how
you responded to that and this was who I
was even before this so when the guys
would tell me before I had this like oh
you don't have an Instagram that's
really cool like a lot of girls that
look like you are usually showing off
their bodies on Instagram and this was
when I did it wasn't sure I didn't talk
to those guys because I think
romantic love should be largely centered
around people who share your values and
so even though I wasn't personally
engaging at this at the time these were
always my values I never correlated
sexual Purity or modesty to morality
ever and so it's not hard to find other
people like that and that really enrages
people because people are like oh
nobody's gonna like you like really
you're speaking for billions of people
on this earth like you think everyone
thinks like you like we're in a culture
War 24 7 in this country like like we're
completely split on what our values are
and what we believe
so no uh hasn't made dating hard
um the only thing that makes dating hard
is the fact that I barely leave my house
and it's hard for me to so tell me about
the reality of only fans because a lot
of people think oh you put up some naked
pictures and you make a ton of money
it's a it's a full-time job it's a
full-time job and I and I want to say
that one of the other hardest things
about this job is
um with being a lawyer like I said it's
so respected everybody like it's like
the whole world is working toward for
you with only fans and sex work it's
like the whole world is against you and
it's not just people it's the platforms
we're constantly de-platformed I've been
banned on Tick Tock more times than I
can count and it's not necessarily their
fault it's the banking pressures it's
the App Store like we are constantly
under threat of Reddit Banning explicit
content of Twitter Banning explicit
content of only fans Banning explicit
content not because they want to but
because Visa Mastercard we're having
this big like anti-porn push from the
right
um who's like oh my God the children
it's always the children oh my God
children so I don't know how much you
know about like the 2018 legislation
that Trump helped pass the sesta Foster
which got rid of Backpage
and did nothing to stop trafficking in
fact trafficking's worse now all it did
was prevent sex workers from having a
safe place to I guess advertise and you
know whatever and so that is still you
know we have States now where they're
making you upload your ID I don't know
if you heard to like watch porn
um yeah there's a few States now that
you have to like that's why PornHub is
like on strike and they won't go into
those they won't um you can't like
access like I think it's Louisiana a
couple others where you can't go to
Pornhub if you try to go to Pornhub it's
like the one of the people that work at
PornHub like contact your Congressman
whatever because they're passing these
laws
um
all under the guise of stopping
trafficking and child safety which it's
not actually contributing to uh but I
mean that's a whole other topic I could
go on and on about but that aspect of it
I didn't expect like I didn't expect
like I come from law where people are
hustling like type A personalities but I
have never seen hustle till I started
seeing what only fans girls do and
online sex workers do never like first
of all they're so kind they're always
willing to like and I can't speak for
everybody but at least in my experience
like there are threads that I would go
to I remember my very first day I was
like I reached out to this girl that I
saw was doing well on Reddit and I'm
like hey this is my first day and she
spent so much time giving me advice
posting me for free like
when the whole world is against us we do
have like kind of like a Sisterhood that
that's been really great to find and
like the only fans community and only
fans I think is really unique because
it's brought in a lot of people into sex
work like myself that wouldn't otherwise
be in it like your local Barista now
hasn't only fans the only fans wasn't
around you wouldn't be doing porn no I
wouldn't be doing any form of sex work I
would make no money as a stripper I hate
sweating I'm sweating now
um I would never no so only fans is like
created a way into the sex industry
where you're literally like okay
post post post like from your room so
tell me tell me what the reality is of
your week uh shooting how often depends
so like Mondays I have the streams I
always I do
um I always have a longer form video for
only fans every other day there's a
friend that I shoot my sex scenes with
now so like every month how long is a
long form
five to ten minutes
um and we meet up like once every month
or every other month and I try to shoot
a bunch of sex tapes at that time to put
out later I have my posts I tried with
another person yes with a friend
um male or female male so I and that's
something is another misconception like
I'm actually very sexually reserved when
it comes to in person like actual
contact like the internet's really easy
for me but I have people that message me
all the time like can you can we collab
I literally can't have sex with someone
that I feel like no kind of did you feel
like when you're on camera you're acting
no and that's one thing about me I could
be making so much more money if I was
willing to open myself up to collabs and
just having sex with people to post on
only fans but I can't do it and I don't
want to ever do something I'm
uncomfortable doing and so even when I
started I only did what I was
comfortable with and I it's very easy
for me to save that because I was
privileged in the sense of like I didn't
need the money I was just doing it to do
it and now that I'm I'm again I'm doing
well but I could be doing so much better
if like even girls are like do you want
to collab I I'm like I would feel so
awkward so like the friend that I have
sex with we were already having sex so
now we just put a camera in front of it
but that's like me authentically having
sex that's not me shooting a scene
that's not me doing something for my
only fan so so you're shooting and
posting every day yes and you also go on
other platforms to promote I go on other
platforms to promote
um yeah I'm trying to actually get more
into doing like social political
commentary just because there's not
there's not even a lot of women
philosophy lessons yes and breaking down
like lost stuff like if a Supreme Court
case comes out like my fans will be like
hey can you talk about you know this or
like affirmative action stuff and I'm
like okay so like it's weird I literally
feel like at a law professor sometimes
like I read more I have to do research
like I'm like how did this become my job
like this is not what I expected in a
million years but I love it do you feel
any shame
no I actually don't and I think the
reason for that and this is what I would
tell anyone who wants to do this is you
have to I would sit there and I would
really and I I can over intellectualize
kind of anything and I'm like okay what
is the problem people keep telling me
you don't respect yourself you don't
respect yourself sitting there I'm like
okay do I not respect myself like let's
really unpack this like let's look up
like you know or objectification okay
objectifying means okay so you're seeing
someone as an object devoid of feelings
and okay well I obviously don't seem to
myself like that because I care a lot
about my own feelings and emotions and I
always I look like I had the biggest
boobs in my school in middle school so I
always was like sexy I guess in a way
um and that never like it didn't make me
happier but it didn't also make me
sadder like it was just so neutral for
me
um so and I never thought my value
because this is what people oh you think
all you're good for is is and I never
thought that like I'm like I'm a [__]
cool person like I always thought I had
a good confidence like I was like I'm
funny and I'm smart and people want to
be around me and yeah I have big boobs
too but I I knew I was so much more than
that then and I know I'm so much more
than that now and I don't care if people
don't see that like I never
so I would sit there and I'm like okay
no it's not that I don't respect myself
it's just that you don't respect me when
someone says you have no self-respect
what they're really saying is that they
don't respect me not that I don't
respect myself and that doesn't matter
to me and also because I think about why
I believe what I believe so much when I
get those comments I see it as an
opportunity to okay you don't like sex
work why
let's talk about it let's duke it out in
the marketplace of ideas so because the
way you feel a lot of other people feel
especially in America and I do notice a
stark difference with my fans depending
on where they're from and how repressed
they are in the way that they express
their sexuality and the way they treat
sex workers I I definitely notice that
like my European fans are just like it's
like a random Tuesday for them hey how
are you can you send me this video and
then like after they're done like oh
that was great thank you just busted
enough everywhere okay bye have a nice
day super chill relax your Europeans are
much more oh yeah but Americans are like
hey like can I see this and then they
like then they get their post not
Clarity then they delete their profile
everything they're like oh my God [__]
[__] [__] and then they come back two
days later it's like this cognitive
um and this has actually been researched
with porn addiction moral incongruence
where they've had like studies where
people they've seen their attitudes
towards porn and how they feel about
porn and how much actually watching it's
not that people who watch a lot to have
this issue it's because people who think
like God is going to punish me you know
those religion that complicates it all
right exactly and being where I'm like
from ethnically and culturally they have
a huge repression problem so you do see
I see like my middle eastern fans
the fetishes they like because sex is so
taboo for them so they like want to get
extra taboo and then they're super
ashamed
um you know they're like and then they
disappear and then they come back and
they they can't just like
be like okay this is normal like I have
a sex drive
I there's not a single fetish that
you're the only person that has it like
people have all kinds of fetishes and
only fans is actually a pretty sex
positive place for that
um something that surprised me is how
many people come on only fans or
um like ask me like they're like it's
like sex education for them especially
guys who don't have a ton of experience
with women like I'll go live on there
and people are like hey what's the best
way to like finger a girl
do do girls like this
do you really want a 12-inch dick like
we see in porn and now you're seeing
like real everyday women like no what
you see in porn isn't like mainstream
porn isn't reality
um they actually even did a study on
this
um that only fans users feel like their
sex lives have gone better because they
feel more open they like to try new
things I have so many couples that watch
me together
2023 all different kinds of
relationships people who find me because
their wife thought thinks I'm or like
you know all kinds of stuff so that's
what's been the biggest surprise since
you started
the biggest surprise since I started and
I guess this isn't specific to only fans
but just in general is
how
uneducated is the word how much people
just don't question the narrative
they've been told like
how much people are just like oh no sex
is bad and it's degrading and I'm like
okay why and they don't know why if you
actually keep pushing like they don't
know why unless they they're religious
and then they can point to like the
appeal to Authority which like I'm not
so I'm like okay that's what you but if
you don't have that it's really hard to
actually you know and a lot of them
aren't even equipped to have those kind
of conversations but they don't actually
know why they believe what they believe
um so I was kind of in this bubble
before where I thought like the
marketplace of ideas would Prevail and
good ideas would Prevail over bad ideas
but then I see the internet and I see
the stuff that appeals to people is like
stuff that
um
like our brains weren't really evolved
to like think critically you have to
learn how to think critically you know
your brain has evolved to kind of when
someone
um
touches that like emotion or anger or
rage and this is what you see like on
Twitter and everything like the angry
you know whatever character tweets and
and this is how people engage with the
world and that's how conspiracy theories
get to what they are um because people
don't have this skill and so one of the
other things I learned is how privileged
I am and how lucky I am when I get these
hate comments from like these and then
sometimes I'll click on their profile
and they're clearly you know not very
you know it's like some 200 pound guy
that's like you know you can tell he
doesn't live the greatest life I can
tell from his the way he wrote that he
isn't super educated doesn't have and
I'm like
there is no reason that I'm here and
he's there other than just pure luck
I had the background I had I have the
jeans I have I have
um I didn't choose that you know
um everybody is just working with what
they have
and even trying to put yourself in
someone's shoes is really hard because
you can only really put yourself in
someone's shoes as yourself with like
your brain and your experience and your
insecurities and your limitations and
then you're trying to put yourself into
like how would I behave if I'm them but
you can't unless you are them
um do you ever wonder if you are
undermining the
Society the fabric of our morality and
Society by you you give such a beautiful
I'm absolutely undermining and I love
that this is such an endorsement for
only fans oh yeah well this is the thing
like I I want to do that I think it
should be undermined we should be like
wait why are we so uptight about sex
right why do we feel this way why do we
shame the stigma stigmatizing sex
workers doesn't help anybody because a
lot of times people are like well most
of these girls are you know like a lot
of the girls you interview have these
terrible lives and they wouldn't be
doing this if they had any other choice
and I'm like okay so why are you calling
them these names because it's not
helping those women when when you talk
this way about sex workers when you say
when you call it all this stuff because
that's just making it harder for them to
come out there they have more shame now
they have more guilt now and it's also I
make this point too I think there are
plenty of women like me who are would be
much happier doing this that are working
some shitty job they hate with an
abusive boss who aren't doing this
because they're still afraid of that
stigma so I don't think it's making
anybody happier
um and it's definitely not helping those
women that you purport to care about
so yeah yeah I think I think seeing you
talk so freely about
how successful you've been and how how
easy this not easy I mean it's a lot of
work but it's yeah it's come to you very
nicely and you're going to be set for
life yeah I it's gonna change a lot of
girls I feel a lot of women's views I
feel a one I feel like I can't fail like
I have to keep going and because
I I feel a pressure
but I also feel a responsibility like
you can't really just come into this
world and take the money and leave you
need to do more you need to serve this
community because you are in a position
and many other women aren't in this
community aren't to actually help
so that's also something I feel so my if
I had like my ideal life yeah I would
retire in five to ten years and then
spend my time you know just kind of
saying [__] it and do what I can to help
I feel like you you're like an
inspiration for that like you just kind
of do you wonder if
you're contributing to some part of
society that's sick because all these
men are just they're staying alone when
they're watching you
you hear that but I don't I haven't seen
like it's not helping them in their
relationships with other women
well according to the two studies it has
the only fans in particular I think only
fans is different like I said I know
very little um also there was a recent
study that came out because people think
oh only fans users are like lonely
single they're actually mostly married I
think it was like 62 from that study I
don't remember if I was looking at it
you can say if they're married and
they're watching is keeping them from
cheating
I can't I can't speak all I can say is
the majority of my fans and maybe I
attract these kind of fans because of my
personality on other platforms they're
super sex positive so nice so respectful
like I said like sometimes it's just
like I don't I'm like the grammar the
puncture everything the word choice like
they're like good evening like comma
like your fans are super I would say
that I I guess I attract that more I
guess White Collar well you're clearly
very intelligent that that might be that
is oh and I get so many people on there
like hey you're really hot but you being
smart is extra hot and that's what made
me subscribe but then you get the haters
all over Instagram like no one cares
what you think like you're just a
[__] family no I don't think that's
true at all well yeah so I don't think
that's true either and I I mean from my
anecdotal experience makes you five
times more yeah my anecdotal experience
bears that out that people like that
um so and I don't encourage those
parasocial relationships I make it a
point not to encourage those
in the sense of like like I said I don't
have like girlfriend experience like a
lot of only fans creators offered that
where it's like I'll pretend to be your
girlfriend for a day if you pay me x
amount of money I'm like I don't think
that's healthy okay so healthy for you
no no no it's just virtual so virtual
yeah like there are guys who really want
to pay for someone to like send them a
selfie in the morning and pretend to be
your girlfriend that's like a common
thing and a lot of girls do it and it's
a money maker and I won't do it because
I don't think it's healthy for them and
I don't think it's even like I don't
well yeah it's just AI is coming so AI
is coming and people clearly there's
that girl the Snapchat did you hear
about that no the Snapchat Creator who
made an AI girlfriend version of herself
and people could pay a dollar a minute
to talk to her
um and she was open about it being and
she made me [__] off of that which is
really interesting the world is changing
but I do think there is still people who
want to just see real and that's one of
the other reasons I think only fans is
what it is because people were sick of
like the you know the oil the tan the
crate like the super fake porn star
mainstream porn thing and then now
they're like I actually want to see the
girl next door I want to see some
stretch marks I want to see
um like a normal female body real women
real women and so like I said I started
on Reddit there's a subreddit for
everything chubby skinny short tall mom
bod people like it all people like he
there is someone for everyone and like
whether you're tall or skinny or you're
thick or you have big boobs small boobs
everything there are people into that
and I think only fans allowed like
the guys who are interested and women
but it's majority men to be like oh I
really want like the MILF next door I'm
gonna go find like an actual mom who is
like doing this where kids are at soccer
practice like that's hot to people
I'm not giving my opinion but I can see
how only fans would be good for
women who had no other option and they
could
do something that they can generate
money to yeah to support their kids or
their family or their life parents
whatever and uh
not have to
do porn they weren't going to make any
money yeah now they can make money oh
porn stars are like they're like I don't
know how much you know about this but
like no one wants to do me anymore
they're all like what the [__] why
especially because of the amount those
women get paid they have no con they
don't own their content as a Jim Sexton
said a couple weeks ago on my channel
it's a betamax uh yeah I think porn is
like a betamax and they
only fans takes 20 the money goes
directly to us it's actually the most
ethical way you can watch porn because
everyone on there is verified they're
super stringent about it because they
don't want to lose their money all goes
to you except for you actually literally
have to have like a bank account in your
name so like what percentage does only
fancy 20 20. so they take 20 you get 80
but again you're verified if anyone else
wants to come on they need to sign a
consent form we need to take a picture
of our ID holding our ID we're taxed
we're 1099 employees
um like I said our bank account has to
match the name so like all of that
exploitation like I'm not saying it
doesn't happen at all but like a pimp
and all of that like it's very difficult
on only or like underage you do this by
yourself I do this completely by myself
you have no partner you have nobody
taking a cut no a managers nope no
agency no managers I don't think I'm not
saying they're all bad but I do think
that you don't need one
only fans cut out the middleman you
don't need an agency you don't need a
manager I literally started like to this
day I do everything on my phone
I just take videos and pictures and
engage with my fans that's what I do the
phones are good enough now that you can
produce content you can yeah the the
when I film my sex tapes uh the guy I
film with is has like experience with
film stuff and so he literally just has
like some light in his the phone we even
shoot those with our phone and he just
kind of sets it up like different angles
and we go for it that's it you don't
need all of that you don't need someone
to promote you you can do it they they
have the access to the same social media
platforms you do like these management
companies really come and they're like
okay we're gonna take 40 but then we'll
post for you you take the picture upload
it in a drive and I'm like wait I'm
giving you 40 you want 40 percent
for
posting what I did and into a drive onto
different social media like there's just
no reason for it but especially these
younger girls that think like oh they
told me that you know or they signed
these contracts that most of them would
never actually be enforceable but they
don't know that you got to have the
hustle to produce yeah regularly and
they come or I have because a lot of
people know I'm a lawyer so I have girls
that come to me and they're like this
management thing I you know that but I
signed this contract I look at this
contract I'm like this is not an enforce
contract because they're like they're
threatening me and blah blah blah and
they've been taking 50 and not doing
anything and I'm like you don't need
these people because that's the thing
anytime there's something where women
are making a lot of money in men come in
and they pretend they're needed they
pretend wait a second pimps are
everywhere yeah exactly they're like
wait wait wait wait wait you guys are
making all this money okay you know you
need me to manage you I'm sorry why do I
need you to manage me like what exactly
why why do I need you to help me take a
picture of my body and put it on only
fans what is that so
um you you're a very business-minded
woman I am and a lot of women exactly
and a lot of women that do this they're
like fresh out of high school 18 19 they
don't know her so that's one of the
things I try to like tell because I I do
see those younger girls that are like
yeah I just signed with this management
agency they're taking 50 but they said
they're gonna make me all this money I'm
like
is it contingent on the making you all
that money and then two months later
they're like yeah they're making me even
less money and they're taking half of it
and I don't know what to do when they're
threatening me and I'm like yeah and a
lot of these management agencies are
just run by Bill down the street who
like was like wait a second I wanna
cause they're trying to hustle too these
guys and this is there's a lot of money
in this sex is I mean look at me I have
a law license and I could not generate
this money my my most lucrative asset is
still sex and my looks doesn't matter
how many degrees I have and you're still
young yet
if you think if you consider 28 young
I feel like people in this industry
think like
30-year expire which isn't true
obviously but that's how they frame it
I'm definitely not like I think I'm
above the average I would say I actually
I'm just completely making that up but a
lot of the really at least popular ones
are actually like mid-20s I would say
but you you can start in only fans when
you're 18 and you can imagine for many
18 year olds they're like wait a second
I want to do that when I'm 18 because
like I don't want to go and
um waitress and whatever for minimum
wage when I could just do this and I'm
like yes but and then I there are things
you need to think about there are
consequences for this and I always go
through that with girls like some girls
like okay I want to start one but I
don't want anyone ever I know to see it
ever I'm like well you're opening
yourself up to that possibility like
everyone's found me right now
like I've had people from high school
just random people be like hey I saw you
on red and you have to be okay with that
you have to be accepting of that if
you're like oh I want this to be
completely secret you can't have it both
ways and make all this money because the
more money you make that means the more
exposure you have
and the more likely it is that other
people are gonna see you
so yeah Jasmine thank you so much for
enlightening us all of course you're
such a big fan of soft white underbelly
well you're gonna have a lot of fans
here I think after after this video I
hope so and yeah I I'm really passionate
it's just nice to see a woman
thriving in in the world people don't
think it's something that gets gets
judged a lot yeah people don't think
it's possible like I guarantee you even
when people see this video they're like
she must have just not told us about her
abuse she must have just not because
I've seen that sometimes in the comment
section of yours oh she's she's coping
she's there's something there has to be
something we're missing that can tell us
why she did this and I'm here to tell
you there really isn't like there really
isn't and I challenge everyone to just
you're just a little more sexually free
than most people I'm sexually free and
and I was like okay people don't like
this people don't like me but why is
what I'm doing actually wrong or are
they wrong but I think I think yours
yours
stance whatever you want to call it
you're what you're doing
ticks off so many people oh triggers
always triggers so many people for so
many different reasons oh the uptight
religious people
um it it does feel some jealousy like
you know I see that sometimes like
especially guys like wait I can't do
that I wish I could just sit there and
I'm like yeah I mean that sucks that you
can't but like maybe gay guys can I
don't know they do but the the top
earners are mostly women on only fans so
they just get one area where women
actually Dominate and men like lose
their minds
they're like no now there's just so much
inequality because I can't take off my
clothes and you have so much privilege
as a woman because of this one area
where female females in the adult
industry out earn men and are more
popular than men it's like that means
this must this must go if men could make
as much money as we were
70 of y'all would be butt naked
not only fans tomorrow
that's funny yeah Joseph thank you so
much thank you